oh come to this video playing stupid
chess yeah and it's in fact very stupid
what does he doing fe5 and f5 so wyd
weird oh okay yeah okay let's let's
protect this pawn and see what happens
III and Bishop c4 would be would be nice
to protect turn I to prevent his his
castling or maybe Knight c3 and and then
then the check iam you should see fo ok
can we can play 95 but it's it's very
ugly
yeah let's just develop
Castle Tyga Bishop c4 check okay
yeah okay well he's just playing some
random moves to be honest i protect c 3
i'll make sure that he doesn't demand
damage my posture should i attack at
five this is the more point thing it's
not so clear how he should prove
protected even with the rookie fade
maybe queen is heaven I can also just
take yeah
yeah not so I can play on hmm can also
just take take this way keep on
preventing this castling Scott no no
good moves any way down I'm already two
points up so it's not a problem a way
that can I can also give the check here
check c6 takes c6 mines no direct
refutation yep just just drop this back
its two pawns i dunno threatening queen
bee five it can exchange queens now but
two pawns and time even intending g4 now
yeah that's that's plenty for why not
so when I'm two points up for basically
nothing and no it's attacking those two
now didn't pay much attention to that
ok let's um keep the sea poem
you can take twice on fo I go to f1 it's
still it's still a good solid extra
point it's not taking the stones I I
really would have taken i think at least
you you get a pawn can I do that yeah
why not threatening h5 now to keep our
c4 even not just the form check what
hmm yeah whatever maybe he just wants to
play some stew Bannock realize oh it was
a 75-minute game maybe we just had a
couple couple of games in them how to
assess his playing strength okay well a
bit of a weird game but thanks for
watching anyway